i'm joined now by the shadow health
secretary jonathan ashwa thank you for
being with us so uh what did you make of
what the health secretary had to say
i thought it was a rather complacent
presentation frankly
we're in a very serious situation now
with the levels of covert infections in
the community which is obviously
knocking on to hospitalizations and
sadly deaths
government ministers have talked about
our wall of defense being vaccination
well our wall of defense is beginning to
crumble because the booster program is
stalling on current trends we won't
complete that program until spring of
next year that's simply unacceptable
we've only vaccinated around 15 percent
of our young people and of course the
infections are concentrated at the
moment in in school children i think
over the last three weeks we've seen
around 10 000 infections a day amongst
children of course the third doses for
the immunosuppressed is stalling and
charities have called it uh chaotic
and the flu vaccine which we also need
to really ramp up is running around 36
percent for over 65s
i wanted to hear from ministers how they
were going to get a grip of this
stalling vaccination program well to be
fair they have to say
vaccination to be fair he said they were
going to accelerate uh the booster
program for the elderly and the
vulnerable i mean what would labour be
doing that the government isn't of
rushing to another lockdown
most certainly not nobody wants to go
back to the dark days of lockdown so nor
do we want to see
the prime minister impose lockdowns on
places like bolton burnley berry and
lester my own which he did uh in the
previous stages of this pandemic what
would labour do well first of all we
need a big ambition we should be doing
500 000 booster jabs a day we're nowhere
near that we should have a target to
to do a larger proportion of our
children by the first of december
who would be doing it because the gps as
we know are um have a considerable
burden they haven't got time to do it
who would be doing it
beauty pharmacy for a start that's what
we should be doing we should be
mobilizing some of the infrastructure we
used earlier on in our vaccination
campaign so let's get retired clinicians
retired men medics back doing
vaccination one of the problems with the
school vaccination program is that we've
seen over 800 school nurses cut under
the tories these last 10 years but why
aren't we using retired school nurses
retired nurses to come and do those
vaccinations in schools and at walking
centers we need more pop-up centers at
mosques at churches in churches in
temples like we've had in the past we
have done this before i don't understand
why we're not doing it now do you think
why we're not targeting 500 000 jobs a
day in order to galvanize our
vaccination campaign at this stage right
do you think the pressures on the nhs
are
unsustainable
i think i think the pressures on the
under the nhs are immense at the moment
and i was i i was frankly shocked that
the uh health secretary was so casual in
dismissing them frankly we've seen
the other day we had a a child with
mental health problems waiting 48 hours
for a bed in ipswich we've had patients
in preston waiting over 40 hours we've
got people we've got ambulances backed
up outside hospitals and of course this
is before we hit the very coldest winter
months so the nhs is not just under
pressure it's underwater so we do we do
need to ramp up this vaccination program
in order to relieve the coverage
pressures on hospital beds okay john
athworth uh ashworth i appreciate your
time thanks very much